what you're talking about I said this
hat with Corey Feldman and stuff you
were there and saw that your whole life
saw what we did whatever has been
happening in Hollywood yeah yeah of
course my friend I'm talking a lot
lately people gave him a lot of [ __ ]
lately do you think they're right or
wrong to say hey you should have named
people receiver like right to kind of go
war like ten million dollars is a lot of
money there's a lot of issues to
separate out with that first and
foremost as he was abused as a child and
that gives him an awful lot of room to
express himself and develop himself and
he's got his whole rationale and they
there's he's been in so many interviews
lately and and you know he should he
should speak for himself about how he
how and why and who he talks about
things but I think it's unfolding
I think it's unfolding well you know I
think he's legitimately opened himself
up for criticism because of the overlap
between personal gain and and a crusade
to help other people but at the same
time a lot of people who support him
don't care they they they they want to
see what he does they want to see if he
can actually help people so as his
friend I kind of have a sober I'm like
it's auntie I'm like are you eating are
you getting enough sleep you know and
and he um he's you know he's he's doing
what he believes is the right thing to
do and people can we'll see you know how
party oh sorry
how far do you think this will go like I
know there's probably a lot of people
who are nervous like oh [ __ ] I'm next
like like you know I mean how well
that's what's happened that's why Cory
is he's been on this thing for his whole
life
since he was you know 14 or 15 he's been
pursuing this kind of oh I don't know
what you say this you know catharsis for
himself and and this sense of you know
need for justice and like wanting to
help other people and everything else
but it's because of the whole Harvey
Weinstein me two watershed moment in
American culture where all of a sudden
you know talking about how we interact
with with each other or the you know
between the genders and stuff like it's
it's galactic what's happening so that's
why he has a new thing let me I'll share
one thing that I you know my daughter my
oldest daughters in college at Harvard
and we were so excited to get her set up
there
and we went back and she's a junior now
but we went back and we we got her in
her dorm room it was so exciting for us
and I went and visited her a couple
months after she had been there and we
got to talking and it was clear she's a
tough girl you know she's she's and
she's did a lot of high school or a high
school experience was she was a
cheerleader she was mock-trial she was
in drama she was like no there was no
grass growing under her feet she was not
a Wallflower she's a go out and get him
kind of a student and an athlete and I
kind of think she was scared she's like
dad you don't understand when I want
from this building to that classroom I'm
passing a bunch of places where I'm a
target people whistle and holler at me
people to all kinds of things and and
what are this as a father all of a
sudden I felt like somebody was pouring
hot water on me like a bucket of hot
water going down my body and I'm like oh
my god I have absolutely failed I failed
as a father I failed as a man I've
failed as a citizen I failed as a kind
of an entity in the in the in the world
because that's how women feel all the
time everywhere they go that's not okay
why is that your failure it's all our
failure because it's my kid and she felt
that way and if she's feeling that way
then it's my fault because she's my kid
is my I take as my personal
responsibility to make sure she's safe
and she's okay and she feels strong you
think that we haven't created I'm
willing to women do deal with a bunch of
[ __ ] that we don't see like just getting
like I don't get catcalled or I don't
have the Menace of the guys in a fort no
you I mean it's it is surprising
sometimes bigger fellas do but it's
scary to like to think like hey the only
reason I'm not being [ __ ] right now is
because this stronger person is choosing
not to like that's a scary way to that's
what I'm saying that's not the only
reason probably that's not in my in my
case with a girl and a guy that they
don't know each other and what's going
on in that moment when they're just
standing watching the thing go from four
to three to two to one
what's what's the energy do they really
feel like fine and comfortable and
totally centered and safe or
is there a little bit of energy and the
fact is that like human sexuality is
just not talked about in the in a way
that is you know the kamasutra we are we
need the American kamasutra so we can
because sex is great and and flirting is
great and interacting with each other
and you know but if you do it absent a
respect and appreciation for how the
other person feels and you're kind of a
dick so what's your what's been your
experience in Hollywood because you've
been there in huge positions kind of all
throughout your life right like every
every stage of your life you've got some
giant movie role at least one if not
multiple pretty giant iconic roles I've
been insulated my whole most of my
almost all my I've been married 26 years
when together with my wife 27 and a half
years so that's a that's a center you
know I mean and in terms of interests a
big question like in turn narrow narrow
well so have you because from an
outsider's perspective I would imagine
that you've managed to avoid a lot of
the pitfalls specifically as a kid like
you you don't hear that was never abused
I was never I never got into drugs and
alcohol not not too much alcohol drink a
little bit but but never like you know I
never try and contrive never like and is
that because if you're your parents is
that because like you know after the
Goonies you're as big a star as Corey
Feldman in that moment as a kid you're
the star that move Corey's talked a lot
about it so I can refer to it but it's
really up for court he say for himself
but like watching him on the set of
Goonies and the lack of parental care
for him
was horrifying I think and it was and we
all loved and cared about him but
there's like only so much you can do
protect I mean he was a cocky kid he was
strong-willed and you know had a lot of
energy and was doing things and I don't
know that you know in a certain moment
you can go hey Corey I want to talk to
you about the lack of parental
supervision you have and let's see how
that's gonna affect your life and you
know in five years you're gonna get
arrested for you know especially when
you're into heroin in your car yeah when
your kid well anybody yeah for no one is
it a successful enterprise to do that I
mean maybe maybe certain people can have
that influence and I regret that I that
I maybe couldn't have been more of that
to him or something but
but he you know but that's that's a big
that's and then there's there's you know
genetic predilections to things and I
just got lucky I parents who love me I
parents who cared about me I had a
father whose expectations of me were
really kind of specific you know he
really wanted me to go to college make
sure I went to college even if I got to
act in shows he really he just wanted me
to get that diploma and have that
experience and it was probably actually
on that level it's probably great that
there was so much show business in your
family because like when you're a kid
and you get this giant movie there's not
this thing that sweeps over your parents
like oh my god our kid is a star our
kids in a movie they understand